[Música]
gracias por seguir con nosotros hoy en 5
minutos con hablaremos con rafael cox
alomar constitucionalista profesor de
derecho en la universidad del distrito
de columbia en washington dice sobre
algunos de los referendos estatales que
se votarían también el martes 3 de
noviembre en eeuu esto quiere decir que
no solo se elegirá al presidente
vicepresidente y congresistas gracias
por acompañarnos señor cox hablemos
primero de los estados que podrían
legalizar el uso recreativo de la
marihuana y que implicaría esto
como como usted señala
hay varias iniciativas puestas ante la
consideración de algunos estados con
respecto al uso recreacional de la
marihuana el próximo martes va a haber
votaciones en algunos de estos estados
en donde los electorados locales van a
tomar la determinación de si se respalda
o no verdad el uso recreacional y
entonces la legislatura de estos estados
tendría que actuar ya que todo depende
de lo que suceda el martes con respecto
a la decisión local que se lleve a cabo
ahora
esto es un fenómeno que se da a los eeuu
en donde en muchos de los estados
conforme sus constituciones locales se
le da la oportunidad al pueblo para que
presente iniciativas populares para que
esas iniciativas pasen el crisol del
electorado y si esas iniciativas son
refrendadas por el electorado pues
entonces la legislatura vendría obligada
a actuar ahora cambiando de tema en
california hay otro referéndum clave y
es el de las empresas de transporte como
über y leaf que deberán cambiar el
estatus laboral de sus trabajadores le
pregunta en qué consistirá este
referéndum
pero en el caso de california esa es la
propuesta 22 a la que usted se refiere y
esa propuesta lo que establecería es que
a los choferes de uber y the lift se les
trataría no como contratistas
independientes regulares sino como unos
contratistas independientes con derecho
a una serie de garantías laborales
verdad como unos salarios mínimos unas
condiciones en unas garantías mínimas en
términos de su compensación en términos
de los derechos que tengan
el tiempo compensatorio y se les
trataría de una manera distinta lo que
estamos tratando en california es de que
la legislatura de california a la luz de
un resultado positivo el próximo martes
entonces se pase legislación en
california así que sobre específicamente
los choferes über y sí
ahora misisipí decidirá si cambia la
bandera actual que tiene el símbolo de
la antigua confederación relacionado
directamente con la esclavitud y también
trayendo a colación todo el movimiento
de blacklight mayor qué opinión tiene
usted de si un sí por el cambio
pero en misisipí va a ser histórico
verdad el voto en misisipí es con
respecto al diseño de una nueva bandera
ese diseño que prevalezca el próximo
martes se le presentará entonces a la
legislatura de misisipí y será la
legislatura de misisipí la que tendrá
que actuar verdad la que tendrá que
refrendar a través de legislación lo que
el pueblo decida el martes ahora resta
por ver el escenario misisipí es un
escenario complejo con una larga
tradición de apego al concepto
segregacionista edad en algunos de sus
estamentos sociales y sería un paso de
avance que misisipí cierre este capítulo
que lo vincula con el pasado
secesionista de decir lo 19 es un paso
importante la dirección correcta ahora
rápidamente otro de los temas es la
prohibición del aborto que piden algunos
de los estados que lo votarán
específicamente en el estado de colorado
es una propuesta sumamente cuestionable
desde el punto de vista constitucional
es una prohibición absoluta del aborto a
partir de los 22 meses de embarazo es
decir a partir del final del segundo
trimestre de embarazo habría una
prohibición eso yo entiendo que da al
traste con el mandato constitucional de
raw contra güey y no sería la primera
vez que colorado respalda una iniciativa
que eventualmente el supremo federal
establece que es inconstitucional
así que si colorado pasará esta
propuesta con toda certeza esto se
impugnaría ante el tribunal supremo de
eeuu eventualmente y no me sorprendería
que causara gran controversia verdad y
si quizás
o sea el catalítico que lleve a que un
nuevo supremo una nueva mayoría tenga es
previamente pasar revista sobre la
constitucionalidad de labor así es
revisitar a robin webb profesor gracias
por estar con nosotros gracias a ustedes
por seguir conectados a nuestro canal
[Música]